To which of the popular vote
isn't it likely to lead you on the
lands of the extreme right,
on certain social issues,
such as immigration.
But there is no taboo subject,
there is no taboo debate.
And I think we have 1 problem on the left,
is that for too long,
there are certain topics that we did not want to deal with.
But I say so,
the question uh of immigration,
the question uh.
On the Defense of French Interests and the Question
also insecurity,
these are topics that we deal with with 1 speech
progressive,
that we must wear.
Well,
I take it by hand the body.
We need today on the left
not to address us only
to those who live in the centers
of the majorses.
We need to go find his workers,
its workers who
felt despised
uh. By uh,
by the left sometimes,
to tell them and show them that there is 1 left
who has never dithered on uh,
the European question,
who has always contested this European construction,
uh, liberal,
uh, who uh
today is running for the European election
and above all,
I think that the left
it's too divided on social debates.
Well, me today,
I am leading a gathering of the left
who wants to do social work,
the question of purchasing power and work
its priorities.
And I think everyone on the left
Should do the same